today's episode is brought to you by the
US Army in a world where every movie is
based on pre-existing books comics and
video games watch the snake of nerd
culture to power its own tale in a movie
based on a pre-existing book based on
pre-existing movies comics and video
games so this is how imagination dies
with thunderous applause ready player
one enter the oasis of virtual world and
lets you be anything you want from a
Navi you joined a boy band to the love
child of David Bowie and Admiral Ackbar
where you can see hear and feel
everything that happens but since you
control it by running on a treadmill in
the skin tight bodysuit the whole
experience probably smells like ass you
should really air out that van
I mean crack a window or something clan
up with five Easter egg hunters who lack
the self-awareness to not call
themselves Gunter's hunters hunters and
Conterra Gunter's as in egg hunters
there's parsable at artemis star-crossed
lovers hiding a tragic secret that
underneath their hot on line avatars
they're both hot offline real people but
she's God of birthmark Oh a faint
discoloration on her face and you can
barely see the most lighting no humanity
Oh
joining them his age who hides the fact
that she's a girl by talking or yours is
tight oh the Japanese martial artist who
in reality is a Japanese martial artist
and show the gamer no one can believe is
an 11 year old boy even though everyone
who's ever beat you in halo ends up
being an 11 year old boy so wait you can
be anything you want and they all went
with slight exaggerations of themselves
come on are you ten foot tall bag of
Funyuns a talking Raptor Alan a cloud
made of microscopic Steve Buscemi's do
something creative watch out for the
evil CEO Nolan Sorento who's got an evil
plan to use the Oasis to make money as
opposed to the current CEO who uses the
Oasis to make money I
bought all these power-ups for this
challenge and I've lost at all I need
one of those okay don't spend all your
money now these Gunter's must find three
keys to win control the Oasis hidden by
an awkward Willy Wonka
using their videogame skills pop culture
knowledge it's based on the best-selling
book by Stephen King who hated the movie
and what they probably could have
guessed just by looking at him his
biggest fear was kissing a crawl because
in this world the best people to run a
trillion-dollar company are the biggest
snobs at a comic-con a fanboy knows a
hater see mom I'm not wasting my life
you go to night school
do you like references oh yeah you
better cuz this movies got more
references than a Big Bang Theory
episode about the Justice League
challenging the Avengers to an anime
edition of Trivial Pursuit full of
obvious nerd touchstones Batman Holy
Hand Grenade for a Gundam dica oddly
specific late 90s tough okay Oh am I
being Punk'd goal denied playing is a
job and an extended sequence that asks
what if Kubrick was so hard of her cash
that he sold the shining to Universal
Studios Florida now let's go to 2001
land I want to ride the space baby so
write a law with visionary director
Steven Spielberg as he brings his
trademark wonder to a tale of an America
and chaos where we ignore our problems
by using recycled pop culture's and
escape and only take action when our
corporate overlords threaten to put more
ads in our pay2win video games while the
offline world continues to slide into
extreme poverty and environmental
collapse who doesn't love a good fantasy
my right good one Steve
starring miles Taylor
I mean Ansel L know I mean all didn't
Ellen right I mean Tyler Sheridan yeah
nailed it
sweet lord no no no don't show together
then meddlesome H to the is org o cool T
G Millers in this said absolutely no one
Arthur slugworth with me and Jo P in a
world of pop regurgitation get good
noobs and this guy staring directly into
the camera while he strangles ty
Sheridan that's unsettling
we are the are troopers
[Music]
Holy Hand Grenade wait this movie is 90%
reverences and you didn't count 1 to 5
before using the Holy Hand Grenade of
Antioch a fanboy knows a hater today's
episode was brought to you by the US
Army find out more by clicking the link
below
needs more gold Boone's Christopher
Robin I don't feel so good
I am the Weaver Stacey's mom has it
going on my silky smooth voice is
smoother than the smoothest have smooth
smooth ease